It's not unusual to find that an application
is organized as multiple communicating processes.
What's the advantage of using multiple processes
instead of just a single process?
Many applications exhibit concurrency, i.e.,
some of the required computations can be performed
in parallel.
For example, video compression algorithms
represent each video frame as an array of
8-pixel by 8-pixel macroblocks.
Each macroblock is individually compressed
by converting the 64 intensity and color values
from the spatial domain to the frequency domain
and then quantizing and Huffman encoding the
frequency coefficients.
If you're using a multi-core processor to
do the compression, you can perform the macroblock
compressions concurrently.
Applications like video games are naturally
divided into the "front-end" user interface
and "back-end" simulation and rendering engines.
Inputs from the user arrive asynchronously
with respect to the simulation and it's easiest
to organize the processing of user events
separately from the backend processing.
Processes are an effective way to encapsulate
the state and computation for what are logically
independent components of an application,
which communicate with one another when they
need to share information.
These sorts of applications are often data-
or event-driven, i.e., the processing required
is determined by the data to be processed
or the arrival of external events.
How should the processes communicate with
each other?
If the processes are running out of the same
physical memory, it would be easy to arrange
to share memory data by mapping the same physical
page into the contexts for both processes.
Any data written to that page by one process
will be able to be read by the other process.
To make it easier to coordinate the processes'
communicating via shared memory, we'll see
it's convenient to provide synchronization
primitives.
Some ISAs include instructions that make it
easy to do the required synchronization.
Another approach is to add OS supervisor calls
to pass messages from one process to another.
Message passing involves more overhead than
shared memory, but makes the application programming
independent of whether the communicating processes
are running on the same physical processor.
In this lecture, we'll use the classic producer-consumer
problem as our example of concurrent processes
that need to communicate and synchronize.
There are two processes: a producer and a
consumer.
The producer is running in a loop, which performs
some computation  to generate information,
in this case, a single character C.
The consumer is also running a loop, which
waits for the next character to arrive from
the producer, then performs some computation
.
The information passing between the producer
and consumer could obviously be much more
complicated than a single character.
For example, a compiler might produce a sequence
of assembly language statements that are passed
to the assembler to be converted into the
appropriate binary representation.
The user interface front-end for a video game
might pass a sequence of player actions to
the simulation and rendering back-end.
In fact, the notion of hooking multiple processes
together in a processing pipeline is so useful
that the Unix and Linux operating systems
provide a PIPE primitive in the operating
system
that connects the output channel of the upstream
process to the input channel of the downstream
process.
Let's look at a timing diagram for the actions
of our simple producer/consumer example.
We'll use arrows to indicate when one action
happens before another.
Inside a single process, e.g., the producer,
the order of execution implies a particular
ordering in time:
the first execution of  is followed by
the sending of the first character.
Then there's the second execution of ,
followed by the sending of the second character,
and so on.
In later examples, we'll omit the timing arrows
between successive statements in the same
program.
We see a similar order of execution in the
consumer: the first character is received,
then the computation  is performed for
the first time, etc.
Inside of each process, the process' program
counter is determining the order in which
the computations are performed.
So far, so good - each process is running
as expected.
However, for the producer/consumer system
to function correctly as a whole, we'll need
to introduce some additional constraints on
the order of execution.
These are called "precedence constraints"
and we'll use this stylized less-than sign
to indicate that computation A must precede,
i.e., come before, computation B.
In the producer/consumer system we can't consume
data before it's been produced, a constraint
we can formalize as requiring that the i_th
send operation has to precede the i_th receive
operation.
This timing constraint is shown as the solid
red arrow in the timing diagram.
Assuming we're using, say, a shared memory
location to hold the character being transmitted
from the producer to the consumer,
we need to ensure that the producer doesn't
overwrite the previous character before it's
been read by the consumer.
In other words, we require the i_th receive
to precede the i+1_st send.
These timing constraints are shown as the
dotted red arrows in the timing diagram.
Together these precedence constraints mean
that the producer and consumer are tightly
coupled in the sense that a character has
to be read by the consumer before the next
character can be sent by the producer,
which might be less than optimal if the
and  computations take a variable amount
of time.
So let's see how we can relax the constraints
to allow for more independence between the
producer and consumer.
We can relax the execution constraints on
the producer and consumer by having them communicate
via N-character first-in-first-out (FIFO)
buffer.
As the producer produces characters it inserts
them into the buffer.
The consumer reads characters from the buffer
in the same order as they were produced.
The buffer can hold between 0 and N characters.
If the buffer holds 0 characters, it's empty;
if it holds N characters, it's full.
The producer should wait if the buffer is
full, the consumer should wait if the buffer
is empty.
Using the N-character FIFO buffer relaxes
our second overwrite constraint to the requirement
that the i_th receive must happen before i+N_th
send.
In other words, the producer can get up to
N characters ahead of the consumer.
FIFO buffers are implemented as an N-element
character array with two indices:
the read index indicates the next character
to be read, the write index indicates the
next character to be written.
We'll also need a counter to keep track of
the number of characters held by the buffer,
but that's been omitted from this diagram.
The indices are incremented modulo N, i.e.,
the next element to be accessed after the
N-1_st element is the 0_th element, hence
the name "circular buffer".
Here's how it works.
The producer runs, using the write index to
add the first character to the buffer.
The producer can produce additional characters,
but must wait once the buffer is full.
The consumer can receive a character anytime
the buffer is not empty, using the read index
to keep track of the next character to be
read.
Execution of the producer and consumer can
proceed in any order so long as the producer
doesn't write into a full buffer and the consumer
doesn't read from an empty buffer.
Here's what the code for the producer and
consumer might look like.
The array and indices for the circular buffer
live in shared memory where they can be accessed
by both processes.
The SEND routine in the producer uses the
write index IN to keep track of where to write
the next character.
Similarly the RCV routine in the consumer
uses the read index OUT to keep track of the
next character to be read.
After each use, each index is incremented
modulo N.
The problem with this code is that, as currently
written, neither of the two precedence constraints
is enforced.
The consumer can read from an empty buffer
and the producer can overwrite entries when
the buffer is full.
We'll need to modify this code to enforce
the constraints and for that we'll introduce
a new programming construct that we'll use
to provide the appropriate inter-process synchronization.